(light music)
- When was the last time
you went in to a store and
physically bought an item?
What was that item?
- I buy nothing.
I mean I literally think the
last time I bought something is
when I went with DRock into that
Nike store a couple episodes of
DailyVee like four months ago.
Bought some Nikes.
I just don't buy shit.
Like food, things
I put in my mouth, I buy.
Like gum and sunflower seeds.
But I don't buy shit.
- Recently started
working on my own business,
my question--
- Sorry.
Yo. Yeah, way better.
How are you?
We're rolling. Let's go.
- Cool. I'm introverted.
I recently started a business.
What are your suggestions for
somebody to hustle their face
off when it takes
everything they have to just
to approach a new situation.
- To get a partner
that can be the extrovert.
Being an introvert and being the
behind the scenes person is a
tremendous strategy and
something that you shouldn't
hide from, that
you should lean in on.
But you need a partner.
- How do I determine if the
employee is the right fit for a
culture from the
culture perspective?
How do I maintain
and inspire loyalty?
- By giving them what they want
and guilting them into loyalty.
51/49 for life.
- What tips do you give to an
entrepreneur starting his own
marketing business in a
somewhat saturated market
and without any budget?
- Hold your fuckin' breath, the
odds are against you which is
perfect 'cause now we
find out if you're good enough.
There's no advice,
there's just execution.
- Ty, can we do live?
- Who was the most influential
friend you had as a child?
What did they teach you
or help to guide you as
you were growing up?
- That's really interesting.
Most influential friend, right?
- Yep.
- That's a good one.
I would say the most
influential friend I had,
most influential friend.
So I was the most
influential friend to everybody.
(DRock laughs)
This literally is like
a Chuck Norris AMA, right?
Influential friend?!?
Who was the most
influential friend?
You know, it's really funny.
This is gonna be
such a big shout out.
I really think that my brother
AJ is the biggest influential
friend I've ever had because he
is somebody I just respect and
I love the way that he
was a straight shooter.
I think he made
me a better manager.
He just inspired me and he's
11 years younger than me but my
brother, believe it or not.
I mean I had great friends
growing up but for some reason
they weren't able to
really influence me but AJ.
- How do you keep
perspective alive when
the shit hits the fan?
- Perspective is binary.
Once you realize that health is
the only thing that matters and
the health of you and the 5 to
15 people you care about most,
it's just that shit hitting
the fan is only when
something is wrong there.
And that you focus on but like
everything else doesn't matter.
- Is it possible to create or
enhance desire or
an ambition for something?
If so, how or is it
you have it or you don't?
- I don't fully know
how to answer this question.
My intuition is it has a lot
more to do with you have it or
you don't than people want to
admit because then it feels like
we're not in control.
But I don't underestimate
manifesting things.
But then the question
becomes is that the having it
or do you don't.
- Right.
- Chicken and egg, right?
- Got to create your own story.
- Yeah but then you
have to deliver on it or
then it's a bullshit story.
Me saying I'm gonna
be an NFL quarterback, tough.
Me saying I'm
gonna buy the Jets,
that felt realistic 'cause
I thought I'd be a big
enough businessman.
So I think there's
some practicality has
to come along with it.
- How do you inspire loyalty?
- By providing loyalty first.
- Two part question:
What is your personal favorite
piece of content and why?
And if it's different what piece
of content do you wish more
people took action on?
- That's super cool.
My favorite piece of content
I ever put out was episode 1 of
Wine Library TV 'cause it was
the first one and all I did was
from the second I decided that
it was a good idea, I did it.
Like literally, within hours.
Within hours of deciding
I wanted to do a wine show on
YouTube, I did it.
And that's why it's
my favorite because it was
me living my thesis.
The piece of content that I wish
more people would consume is
my podcast #righthook.
(group laughter)
What's going on over there?
- [Tyler] Poor connection.
- Keep going.
- When you were a teenager you
said that you knew the internet
was going to be a big thing.
- [Tyler] You
want me to reset it?
- What do you think the next
big thing will be in 10 years?
- The internet
was a unique platform.
It was so unique.
The internet is one of the
5 to 7 biggest things that have
happened to the human race
so I don't know if I'll ever see
anything like that again.
Maybe, maybe virtual
reality ecosystem. Right?
So, I'm not sure.
I don't predict, I react.
- How often have you been
made aware that people have been
turned off by what
you have to say due
to your intensity and honesty?
What is your response
to this kind of perception?
- I'm fully aware,
I'm 100% aware.
My response is I'm a mirror.
What I do makes people reflect
on who they actually are and
people that don't like what
they're hearing have to dig deep
and figure out why because I'm
coming from a very good place
and I'm suffocating bullshit.
I'm also not
asking for anything.
We need to have that
conversation one day.
Like, I'm not
creating all this stuff for
some funnel to my $1,100 e-book.
- How can an influencer make
money besides product placement?
- By creating a product or
service to sell to the audience
that gives them attention.
I am an influencer that has
never taken
$1 in product placement
but I've built a
half a billion dollar valuation
agency on my influence.
- [DRock] You
like that one, Colin?
- I like it.
- It's true.
- Yeah.
- Built a $400 million
valuation business on the
back of my personal brand.
Forget about valuation,
that's just a bigger number.
I built $150 million
revenue business.
- How should one weigh the
differences between pivoting or
throwing in the towel on
an idea or goal versus
continuing to plow ahead?
- Impossible to
answer at a macro.
On a micro, I'd have to spend
a lot of time and figure it out.
However, even if
I audited it correctly,
the person making that
decision has to be ready
for one or the other.
That's the only way
to make that decision.
- Who are the top
influencers in business,
media and technology that
we should be listening to?
- I have no idea.
And to go back to that, it's
because I'm not consuming it so
I don't want to put anybody
on without really knowing
what they're about.
You know, whoever is bringing
you value at the moment.
Feel free to pivot
once you've extracted
the value out of that person.
- What are some of your
predictions as to where social
media is heading in
the next 5 to 10 years?
- Higher.
(group laughter)
- How do you get your foot in
the door with a sports agency
such as Vayner Sports?
- By cold emailing and
DM'ing everyone involved in the
decision making process.
P.S. This will not
work at Vayner Sports.
(group laughter)
- Do you feel like college
taught you valuable business
tools or do you feel
like majority of your business
knowledge came
from other sources?
- I feel like all of
my business knowledge
came from other sources.
I learned nothing in college...
from a business standpoint.
I learned a lot
about from college from a
growing-up-as-a-man standpoint,
from a swag standpoint,
from a basketball standpoint,
from a hip hop music standpoint.
Zero business.
- How do you overcome
uncertainty when time is the
most finite
resource we all have,
how do you
decide to spend yours?
- I spend no time
debating the crippling
nature of the finite resource.
I spend all my
time just doing and
adjusting to what's happening.
- Is there anything practical
I can do every day to stay
consistent and motivated?
- One more time.
- Is there anything practical
I can do every day to stay
consistent and motivated?
- Make pretend that
your family died today.
- I'm a 36-year-old father and
husband with two little girls
but looking to change my career.
How would you go about this when
you have people
depending on you?
It's tough and it's scary.
- Yeah.
So the way I would do that is
by auditing my schedule
and deploying every minute
that I'm selfishly using for
myself for escapism, watching a
game, hanging out with buddies,
and I would allocate that
towards building the base of my
business online with
no cash risk which
A.K.A. means producing content
and a personal brand as a
leverage point to the
business I wanted to build.
Because at the end of the day,
you can't take the risk of the
rent and the food and shelter
and the clothes that you need to
put on your family's back.
So, the answer to
the question is to hedge.
Practical hedge.
It's called practical hedging.
You know, you're basically
sucking out all the things that
you're wasting time on that
isn't binary to building your
business and taking
care of your family.
Everything else is out.
That's what
I did in a lot of ways.
Outside of the Jets,
I've suffocated leisure.
This is a weird day.
All this down time.
I was trying to find, you know?
- You said that--
- People are tired up in here.
(group laughter)
Tyler, people are tired.
- You said that if someone wants
to find their passion they must
try new things.
How should I start?
Where should I look
for these possible actions?
YouTube, blogs, internships.
- Yep.
- My business is growing, should
I continue increasing my product
portfolio or focus in on
improving marketing and sales?
- Both.
- How would you monetize
a Facebook fan page--
- Colin gets pumped.
When he likes an
answer he gets fired up.
- How would you monetize a
Facebook fan page that is based
on a TV show?
- You can run ads,
I mean. Go back.
Facebook now has a pre-roll
and post-roll ad product that
they're rolling out.
You'll be able to
monetize through ads.
You can do affiliate marketing
and sell t-shirts and things of
that nature for
sites that sell products.
You can create your own product
and service and sell it through.
Guys, when you're done,
guys there's kinda three
ways to make money, right?
You sell services,
you sell something,
right, or you sell advertising,
the attention it has.
There's not that
many ways to make money.
Products, services or attention.
That's what you're selling.
- What do you think of
cryptocurrency and are you
planning to invest?
- I have invested, years ago.
I plan on investing more in
the future to educate myself.
But this is an arena I haven't
gone deep enough in yet and so
I don't feel comfortable really
putting my oomph behind it.
- For someone that has what
might be perceived as a boring
but valuable product or
service like personal insurance,
how would you recommend that
they develop an audience or
produce content
that is interesting?
- By talking about things
around somebody's life and going
through life and not
about the insurance itself.
So maybe talking
about lifestyle hacks,
realities, creating content
around what it's like to be 30
to 80 years old, not
about the insurance itself.
Bringing value in other
areas you know like
health and wellness
or vacation advice.
Using content as a gateway drug
to the insurance product around
the psychographics
of the person.
- How much of your effort--
- [DRock] You actually
haven't said that a lot.
Psychographics of the
person you're trying to get.
- Yeah. It's true.
Means it's an important point.
Sometimes I keep
stuff to the vest.
- Tell a story about
a real person's life.
How much of your effort or
online presence are you going to
shift to audio in
the next 12 to 24 months?
- One more time.
- How much of your time and
online presence will you shift
to audio in the
next 12 to 24 months?
- One more time.
(group laughter)
- How much of your effort
and online presence
will you shift to audio?
- A substantial amount
but it won't be shifting,
it will be in addition to.
When I do things,
if I'm rolling,
it doesn't come at
the expense of something,
it's added on to something.
- When do you go to sleep?
Do you try to go to sleep at a
find time every night or every
day or is it most
often beyond your control?
- My normal is 12 to 6.
My Russian is
I understand everything,
I have a heavy
American accent when I speak it.
I can't read or write.
- If you're just
starting on social,
do you fire with one
channel or use all guns?
- You have to
reverse engineer yourself.
All guns is always better but
you may not be capable of that
and then you want to
go with one channel so
that's a very personal question.
Comes down to energy and desire.
You know what, I don't
talk enough about desire.
Well, I use ambition, right?
Are they the same?
In some ways, right?
They're similar-ish.
Help me here with some grammar.
- [Tyler] I think that your
ambition would
have to match your desire.
- [Gary] What is desire?
I desire, I want.
Both of them sound like I want.
- Like your dreams or like--
- [Gary] What's your ambition?
- Yeah but your ambition
needs to match
your dreams, right?
- [Seth] So does
desire drive ambition?
- I don't know.
Whatever it is,--
- [Tyler] I have a
desire to buy the Jets but--
- My ambition
is to buy the Jets.
(DRock laughs)
I feel like you
are doing a bad job,
Tyler, describing the
difference. Yeah, terrible.
But I know I just have
more of it than all of you.
(group laughter)
Alright, let's
keep it goin'.
- You say horrible times are
coming for brick and mortar and
retail, do you have any
suggestion on how small brick
and mortar firm
can counteract this?
- Yes, by developing
their online presence.
- I just launched
a fashion beauty blog and
a YouTube channel.
What are the best strategies
for growth because
this is a saturated market?
- Quality content, continuity,
business development with people
that have audiences
to bring you awareness.
Rinse and repeat.
- What do you think about native
advertising in general and
about platforms like Taboola?
- Native advertising as it's
defined today is diminishing in
it's value but native
advertising is phenomenal.
It's means you're integrating
into content in a more seamless
way than disrupting
the cadence of the reader,
listener or watcher.
- Why Apple and not Android?
- For me, Apple
was just out first.
I don't know if it was out first
in real life but I just got on
the iPhone earlier
than Android and just,
and like many people, creature
of habit and have been happy
with my experience.
Plus, app culture really
solidified it because the apps
that I wanted were
always available on Apple first.
- If you accidentally stumbled
upon enough money to buy the
Jets today, would you?
And if so, what would
you set your sights on next?
- Yes. Super Bowls.
- Are you coming to
Australia any time soon?
- Yes, November.
Details to come.
- What's your take on quality
over quantity when it comes to
content or product variety?
- Both.
Am I right about Australia?
November, right?
- [Tyler] Think so.
- November 7th and 9th I think.
- Thoughts on Anchor
and it's new experience with
audio/podcasts and the
opportunity for creators.
- Over the last 48 to 72 hours,
I've heard a ton about it in my
social but I've been so busy
promoting Planet of the Apps and
running VaynerMedia
I haven't had a chance to look.
I'll look over it next week.
I need somebody, actually,
I need everybody
to figure it out.
- Gotcha.
- Need you to figure that out.
- What should I do
for the business I want
to start already exists?
- Do it better.
You mean like every fuckin'
business on Earth, Luke?
- Exactly.
(group laughter)
- What are the habits or
principles you'd focus
on most right now?
- Work ethic, listening...
That's it.
- When's your
next book coming out?
- January 2018.
Tyler's looking up ambition.
Crushing it.
- Desire's in the
definition of ambition.
So desire's wanting
something to happen,
ambition is pretty much
desiring plus execution.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Desire's wanting
something to happen.
Ambition is the
desire plus the execution.
- [Seth] Got one more.
How do you get
yourself out of a funk?
- [Gary] Perspective.
Cool?
- Yeah.
- Good, let's get out of here.
(light music)